the FBI went too far to hear U.S
conservative media tell it this report
is a huge story something of this nature
takes down the entire organization a
major bombshell and former president
Trump quickly took to social media
claiming it was treason and the crime of
the century but experts close to the
case say that in reality it doesn't
actually say any of that here are some
of the concerns that the Durham report
raises were already flagged before so my
impression so far is that there isn't a
whole lot new here that hasn't already
been identified but I don't think it's
any kind of a win for Donald Trump or
for his current campaign uh that he says
it is John Durham who is appointed by
Trump officials was critical of the FBI
for an investigation based on unanalyzed
and unsubstantiated intelligence but he
only brought three criminal cases
against low-level people two were
acquitted and one pled guilty to a
falsifying an email and did not serve
any time in jail but the investigation
Durham was looking into which turned
into the probe by special counsel Robert
Mueller did see significant arrests
eight top Trump officials found guilty
of serious crimes so of course the big
question is is this going to impact
Trump as he tries to win the presidency
again probably not he has just recently
been found guilty of battering a woman
and then defaming her ordered to pay
five million dollars he's facing 34
felony counts in Manhattan for his
business dealings he's under
investigation in Atlanta for potential
election interference and there is
another special counsel investigating
whether or not he had a role in the
January 6 Insurrection and whether he
stole reams of classified documents and
then tried to hide uh hide them and not
give them back to investigators all that
said what Trump has done with every
single one of these cases is he's used
it to successfully fundraise Patty
culhane Al Jazeera Washington
Thailand's top two opposition